When monetizing an e-commerce site,
there are four main principles
you should keep in mind.
First, let users explore
before they commit.
Second, let users purchase as guest.
Third, make it easy to
finish from another device.
Four, use existing information
to maximize the convenience.
Now let's go deeper on each rule.
Requiring a log in or account creation
too early in a site experience can be
harmful to conversions.
Beware of making enemies
at registration gates.
Don't require customer account
registration up front.
We understand that getting access
to the customer information and
preferences can be integral
to your website success.
But don't ask for
it too early in the process.
You can see here on the left side,
an example of a pop-up that could block
the users from achieving her goals.
However, here on the right side,
you could be productive and
browse the site right away.
Offer the option to
check out as a guest and
encourage registration
with tangible benefits.
If purchasing is something that people
can do on your website, then you want to
aim for the option to clearly enable
users to check out as guests.
The guest option is universally
preferred when users didn't have
an existing account.
At the end of the guest
checkout process,
you have another opportunity to
get users to create an account.
And you can communicate tangible
benefits to them for doing so, for
example, so
that they could track their order.
Also remember that you don't
want to negate the benefits of
free users' purchase by having
a process that isn't smooth here.
All browsers including the ability
to auto complete forms, so
make sure you are using them.
Offer an easy way to save or
share information across devices,
providing functionality to allow
users to pick up where they left off.
Seek opportunities to
scaffold users behavior and
facilitate cross-channel conversion
through your mobile website.
Your users move from one
device to another, or
simply want to go back to where
they were on the same device.
This functionality
could help them a lot.
As you could see here, they could email
it or share it on social networks.
Please take advantage of
information you already have or
use third party payment service to
make conversion as easy as possible.
Another useful way to streamline
the conversion's experience for
users is to know and
use what already exists in terms of
information that the user has provided.
We also find that autofilling, when
possible, was a huge benefit to users.
To learn more about it,
just click on this link.